there's been fury in australia after it
was announced that novak djokovic has
been given a medical exemption from
needing a covert jab to be able to
compete in the australian open djogovic
has always avoided talking publicly
about vaccination status but the
exemptions caused huge controversy
amongst tennis fans and players here's
what the british doubles player jamie
murray had to say
i don't know what to say about that
really
i mean
you know i think if it was
me that wasn't vaccinated i wouldn't be
getting an exemption
um and that's
you know but
well done you know well done to him for
getting cleared to
come to australia and
and compete
sky australia's samantha chiari has the
latest from perth
overwhelmingly since this news broke
late last night there has been uproar in
regards to this decision now there's
been a bit of confusion surrounding how
novak djokovic got approved to enter the
country
particularly given the strict stance uh
the victorian premier daniel andrews has
on being vaccinated in order to enter
the state and he was approved by otagi
so he wasn't approved by the victorian
government or tennis australia it was
all done through atari which of course
is the medical body which gives
exemptions for people to enter the
country if they're not vaccinated since
this news broke there has been no
support whatsoever for novak djokovic
from media commentators to just your
average australian on the street
everyone is up in arms over this
decision particularly given the strict
arduous conditions many melbournians
face now the australian open takes place
in the capital city of victoria which is
melbourne they've had two years of
lockdown the most locked down city in
the world and they have very strict
conditions in regards to being
vaccinated in order to just enter the
pub
so in saying that you'd be close to
saying there hasn't been any any support
uh if any for the world number one novak
djokovic it's certainly going to be an
interesting tournament taking place from
january 17.